welcome to this edition of bonehead of
the week boy gabe we have a lot of
boneheads but one worked their way in
right there at the end dude this
happened
hour it came in
i mean you were making graphics and this
dude is getting eviscerated in number 47
right in this affidavit i tweeted 45
runs into number 47 on the affidavit
isn't that funny yeah he's number 45
they claim he wants to be number 47
number 47 on this affidavit i don't know
i mean i also want to point out the fact
that like when when people spell out
treason with 45 it's like man that just
seemed to really work for that right
4 5
o n like we got that treason right just
it works perfectly you know other than
the fact that 45 looks like the revised
swastika that i've seen people do online
but
i don't know man trump he
really put himself into a [ __ ] [ __ ]
show here
it's almost like he stole a bunch of top
secret documents stuffed them in a box
and put them in milani's underwear
drawer i'm just saying so who are our
boneheads of the week this week besides
grandpa poopypants we have on the docket
we have marjorie taylor green
she's done a lot of dumb [ __ ] but this
week um she continues to do the
boneheaded stuff we have devin nunes
speaking speaking of donald trump and
his lack he's devin nunes he's bone end
of the week and then we have ben shapiro
um you know we put him on the list for
something but i think he did something
else this morning that would qualify him
to be on contestants of bonehead of the
week are you looking at up there
i don't know what he did i don't know he
didn't listen i can look it up right now
though
well yeah well thanks for joining us on
bone end of the week every single friday
for all the new listeners out there on
the tony michaels podcast here's what
happens to let you know how bonehead of
the week works you just go follow us on
twitter at
or you can go to our channel on youtube
at tonymichaelspod subscribe there and
you can vote every single week gabe for
bonehead of the week
you vote you decide and me and gabe
break it down here on the tony michaels
podcast in the second hour on friday
in the segment we like to call bonehead
of the week every single friday gabe we
got great news this week
it's always happening always updating
[ __ ] is always hitting the fan over here
as dash dabrowski says big news big news
we are on we are on the midas touch
network friday nights i'm not i don't
think we still worked out a time so
whatever time we're here
we're here that we're here so if you're
watching this on the minus touch network
on friday evenings you're watching the
replay of this show and don't miss the
replay on the midas touch network make
sure you go over and subscribe to their
channel as well you do not want to miss
this gabe the other thing for all the
new listeners for bonehead of the week
out there we put this thing up on the
directories on sundays yeah you can
listen you can even listen to the hand
of the week
drive to the park take a look walk
listen to whatever you want
of the week i love this segment this is
one of the best ones of the week
so let's start out let's start out let's
go to devin nunes first that won't take
long to describe why he's a bonehead so
what's the truth because he's on here
for true social right is that what's
going on so what is the
what's the big news about true social
well what do we got going on my surprise
if you couldn't have expected it which
you totally should have uh truth social
trump's social media app that was
supposed to go against twitter truth
social turns out that they might be in
significant financial disarray
it looks like they're stiffing one of
their vendors they've only made a few
payments of an agreement they've vendor
vendor what do you mean by vendor
because i think this is important um
for true social because it sounds like
where they house all their data and all
the information that makes it operate
and run it sounds like they're not
paying the bill to be there is that
what's going on that's pretty much what
they owe around 1.6 million dollars to a
company called right forge and now right
forge is threatening legal action to
recoup the money um they've only made i
think about three payments uh i mean
like again could anyone have guessed yes
we could have from the get-go that truth
social would have stiffed anyone that
they were working with they might make a
couple payments here to show some good
faith but then they'll be like what
we're not going to do anymore and that's
that's the same business practice that
trump has done with all of his
businesses right any sort of contractor
maybe pays him a little bit doesn't pay
him the rest or he just doesn't pay him
at all and then he just tries to spread
it out through court and try to fight
him that way and you know sometimes
people win and a lot of times people
lose just because they don't have the
the resource of the funds to actually
fight illegally
but again
totally expected totally here is from is
from a fox business correspondent yeah
shouldn't you it was fox business who
released this scoop
the fox business network no there's fox
news is turning on trump man they have
that other people the other day that was
talking about how the search of
mar-a-lago was justified right well this
puts this is the reason why devin nunes
worked his way on bone end of the week
because he's he's also gonna he's gonna
be the fall guy for whatever happens oh
why i think i think that's the actual
story here on devin nunes is
not not only are they now they're in
they're up to their eyeballs in debt now
um which is funny because i'm i'm
guessing that they'll go ask for uh
forgiveness oh wait wait
you're saying that they're going to ask
for some sort of i bet they would ask
forgiveness
not not hypocritical at all or anything
like that hypocrisy that i name is the
republican party now for fraud social to
stay afloat because that's the other
story around true social really is that
they're being investigated um by the
federal exchange commission because of
some of their when they're raising money
when they were laundering uh the raising
of money originally and then donald
trump's like hey devin nunes come be my
fall guy give up your seat in congress
and come be my fall guy that's a good
idea devin nunes is like
move on over i'm coming in
and there he was what what no i just you
know you don't like how he haven't said
he run over i mean he was very excited
for sure i mean any good cow pun
obviously for a very sensitive triggered
snowflake like devin nunes who has to
sue a twitter account
uh
really tells you who they are you know
yeah well i i just figured if if
if devin nunez is gonna say move on over
he would say
oh yeah no he would for sure
you know kind of exaggerate that out
cows don't actually say mood you know
that they go what
oh okay yeah well i grew up on a farm so
i know i'm like oh right right right
okay yeah yeah so they don't they don't
actually move well i mean it sounds a
little bit like a moo but like that's
when you're trying to get a kid like
what's the cow say moo moo moo moo oh
right old macdonald right had a farm oh
mcdonald oh damn nunes had a farm
yeah
my god who's the next bonehead that we
have
we've got uh ben shapiro now what
happened here he went to a podcast event
yeah he went to a he went to a podcast
event uh there was also talks that uh
he had taken ppp loan money oh no wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
he paid it back no no no i just want to
clarify so basically he had a tweet that
went after
uh
you know it says
what was the original tweet that he had
um
it was
it was his you know the current
hierarchy education industry as
subsidized by the federal government is
a massive scam it is an elitist project
rostering unnecessary credentialism
pushing forward uh or pushing people who
shouldn't take on debt to go to college
to do so paid by progressive
retributionism now i agree i higher
education is is a broken system that
needs to be reformed in many many well
and it's like it's a cultural issue and
association not necessarily i mean
because we put ourselves in a situation
where so many people can
you know make money
convincing people to do something with
their lives that maybe isn't the best
opportunity now so here's the here's the
problem right ben shapiro says that
higher education the the whole industry
is an elitist project fostering
unnecessary credentialism
funny funny considering the fact that
ben shapiro went to ucla which is all
about in la and this is a very very
expensive school since elitist to me
he's a little bit elitist and i mean if
we're going to talk about elite schools
let's talk where else did he go where
went to harvard we went to harvard
you taught you telling me that ben
shapiro is some kind of an elite no it
couldn't seem that way it would seem
that way it couldn't be
but but there was also this tweet it was
a
a doctored photo that said ben shapiro
took out 20 000 or so dollars
uh with ppp loan money right because he
was also so this was a fake this was a
fake turns out it was fake so he did not
take out twenty thousand dollars in
forgiven pvp loan money though it it you
know that that's not to say that it's uh
it's untrue because it is true for
another contestant we have
on this week's bonehead of the week
but i just wanted to clarify for anyone
listening or watching that the money
that you may have seen allegedly he had
taken in ppp money
not true not true well he showed up in
the news yesterday ben shapiro not about
the ppp but there was this thing a
podcast movement down it's like like a
convention a podcast convention down in
dallas texas yeah we were actually we
were yeah we were considering going to
it it was pretty expensive but we just
we couldn't work it out on the schedule
yeah but um the podcast movement put out
a statement because he showed up
unannounced because she had to have
we were looking at the tickets and stuff
right yeah and you could do like a group
ticket or you could buy a booth or you
could just get like an individual yeah
just like an attendee pass right right
and you could select different uh places
that you wanted to go and different like
talks that you wanted to attend right
but they had a general conference area
where you go to booth to boot the booth
now if people won't know ben shapiro is
famously uh the vile nasty owner of the
vile nasty media group the daily wire
where people like ben shapiro show
matt walsh that [ __ ] bigot all that
all that garbage comes out of um but
podcast movement they
they actually did the thing where they
rented a booth to the daily wire and
they they regretted it very quickly
because here's their statement here's a
statement from yesterday hi folks
hi folks we owe you an apology before
sessions kick off for the day
yesterday afternoon ben shapiro briefly
visited
the pm 22 which is the podcast movement
2022 expo area which the expo is the the
you know the big conference area near
the daily wire booth
though he was not registered or expected
we take full responsibility for the harm
done by his presence
oh you can't make this [ __ ] up you can't
make this [ __ ] up so literally the uh
the podcast movement here the conference
is saying that it because ben shapiro
showed up and just his mere presence
causes harm this is a fantastic burn
here and i think they made up they made
up for the um
their lack of
wherewithal to understand that if they
rented a booth to the daily wire that
maybe just maybe uh ben shapiro would
show up they continue to say in this
thread there's no way around it
we agreed to sell the daily wire first
time booth based on the company's large
presidents and podcasting
the weight of that decision is now
painfully clear shapiro is is a
co-founder and a drop in however
unlikely should have been considered a
possibility
so they know the error of their ways but
to me to me gabe they totally made it up
by this uh by this statement yeah it is
totally dolly made up yeah probably made
up for it so i i would go i would
consider going to the uh the podcast
movement next year yeah just because of
this statement
i'm almost disappointed that we weren't
able to pull it together at the last
minute i think it's down there adam adam
was down there right now yeah what yeah
because we interviewed um adam epstein
uh
tuesday wednesday wednesday so he was
probably there that's probably where he
was
uh was getting i was wondering i was
like why it looks like a hotel room yeah
it looks like
so he's probably in the expo i just i'm
i'm disappointed that i didn't go
because we didn't get to participate
with all the other podcasters that would
have been fun but here's one next year
next next year next year but here's what
you're doing i want to say
i'm really disappointed that i wasn't
there to be within spinning distance of
i'm not saying i would i just within
spitting this i mean i wanted to be
close to ben shapiro you know to yell
something
but spitting distance of him
to be within spinning distance of it
might might be something that i would
want to do uh who else do we have on the
bone ed we have we have someone who is
charlie kirk's stepbrother known as
alpha charlie kirk what happened here
with charlie kirk in turning points usa
oh boy well they they had a tweet which
i'm sure you can easily find now they
ended up deleting that tweet oh really
because they whoever wait wait he self
scale self canceling they're they're
doing it yeah they're they're
suppressing their own voice tony they
are suppressing the voice couldn't be
couldn't be but
they had a tweet
that was in response to
uh the white house
and how they were calling out i believe
it was the it was the white house's
response uh yes it was to marjorie
taylor green it was my i quote
and this is why i always take a
screenshot tony because someone is going
to get called out and someone is going
to delete it and now
nobody knows the context of what
man look at this see i quote tweeted
their tweet because they go to uh go
down
i've got it i've got it here i've got it
here but this is why i take screenshots
this is what happens see i quote tweeted
him and i said you're gonna [ __ ] when
you hear who shut this [ __ ] down
yeah so there's no context because the
tweet is deleted right
because i asked
boom boom just from yesterday but here
if you want to know
of course people of course of course
people screenshot this damn thing
because they knew they would be in
trouble midas touch says yikes that's
all you really had to say here because
here is the here's the the
the screenshot of it
the white house tweeted well it was a
whole thread really yeah and that's what
i want to get into here yeah that's why
i wanted which yeah of course we'll lead
us into that's what i'm going to do who
is our last contestant of the of the
dark i mean the white house um rising
from the ashes here um they they were
pointing out in this thread
that um republican politicians who now
say it's unfair and people who are going
to receive the benefits of the student
debt uh relief plan that will actually
be given a one-up in their in in their
life and all the interest that they paid
it probably won't even amount the
interest that they paid over the life of
these loans for some of them
um but the white house was just simply
pointing out all the republicans who are
now saying this but were received
hundreds of thousands sometimes millions
of dollars also
forgiven
why do these people need that money
that's right well why well why they need
it and why they have to have it forgiven
are they lazy is it unfair i don't know
and the other the other thing i want to
bring up is that these are people who
had
the they had uh insight beforehand they
had insider information saying they knew
that the pandemic and they needed to
know that they needed to happen well i'm
saying i mean obviously we all knew the
pandemic but they knew the extent to
which the government was going to at
least aid people and they said oh we
should offer government assistance to
businesses and those people said well i
have a business right well i've got all
i have i have some people i can pay you
know what we should do is we should pile
on all kinds of money for businesses
just like i own okay but turning points
usa really stepped in it here they
really [ __ ] stepped in it because
this was their response to the white
house
about ppp loan forgiveness
they said we won't have had we excuse me
we wouldn't have had ppp loans if it
wasn't for you shutting down the entire
the country down you meaning the white
house right yes that's what they meant i
mean in in some ways that is true right
the white house did shut down did shut
down the government they did shut down
that the government they shut down the
country right to stave off the pandemic
actually they did shut down parts of the
government because you know they had to
do that
but who was in uh who and i that's why i
said you're gonna [ __ ] when you find out
who shut down this [ __ ] because
right they apparently do not know that
the white house every four years it can
change i guess crazy crazy kind of funny
well i mean it can change if you follow
democracy right right right well yeah it
won't change if you had someone like i
don't know trump who thought that he
deserved to be the president because
he was gonna have people just you know
storm the capital and overthrow and
change the the electors so it gets
better
um a lot of i'm you should go
it's too bad they deleted it but there's
plenty of people who screenshot all
their comments and stuff wait who do you
think was the president the beginning of
the pandemic um and then
uh
and i just want to say
this took
way longer than i expected to get
deleted oh like they whoever whoever
wrote this tweet either charlie kirk or
someone within the consecutive the the
cuck conservative crew or whatever you
want to call them
they went through and they said ah man
we [ __ ] got him we so got him on this
one yeah [ __ ] they thought it was
shakalaka they probably joked about it
in a room with other people they said
yeah that's [ __ ] good man they typed
it out read it one more time to
themselves and they go yeah that's good
boom send tweet
and then you think they when do you
think they went took a [ __ ] or something
and that's what i think i don't know i
mean i think they want to go do some
like ball tanning but oh i see yeah well
apparently at turning points usa they
have a ball tanning room right you know
it's it's called the man room
yeah the man room right and so they came
back and they have the boats around it
yeah they have the man
the man cave right uh but they they came
back probably at some point oh man this
this tweet's blowing up it's going viral
and they really go oh [ __ ] not for the
reason we thought oops oops olivia
points out here this is a screenshot
again from the deleted tweet she said it
brings me great joy to watch you
publicly embarrass yourselves why don't
you call your daddy donald and tell him
you didn't like his ideas because she's
so
so elegantly i mean it was a simple
duckduckgo search tony they could have
just searched a long time to figure this
out who was the president during the
shutdown right i mean right it didn't
take that long i mean really honestly if
you could be like who yeah it's like who
was the president when ppp loans were
given out
what a bonehead so that's why charlie
kirk
made it on the alpha cut because boy did
he get cucked by the internet oh boy
charlie you suck and it sucks to suck
wow that's charlie kirk for you we have
we have a dishonorable mention today and
we've been we've been talking about it
here on the show for a while and anyone
uh who missed the first part of show or
if you're re-watching this on the midas
touch network just the bonehead of the
week part of this this the segment uh
you would know that uh this morning as
we were on the air the affidavit um from
the department of justice the courts
released the affidavit that was used to
obtain the search warrant for mar-a-lago
so
naturally at the very last moment in the
11th hour as gabe says
donald trump became the dishonorable
mention because not only do we have our
three contestants here on bone of the
week gabe we put this poll out what time
was it last night that this poll went
out
oh it was late i think people people
were messaging us on twitter like hey
you got to get the i know well i i
i had my own stuff going on yesterday i
had to get my car fixed do all this
crazy it was a crazy day we used to do
the bone end of the week poland earlier
in the week yeah like
monday right but what we figured out was
like it was totally irrelevant by the
time we got to friday because there's so
many [ __ ] boneheads in these manga
republicans there's so many of them that
by the time we got to friday it was a
complete different setup i mean things
can change as we see within just minutes
before i'm making all of the videos and
assets here like i'm like oop this is
who's going to be this this is going to
be that right that's where this
honorable mention and the alpha cut came
from right because we needed we needed
the ability to do that last minute
bonehead thing yeah and we've been doing
it we've been doing it since the first
the first episode but when we were
talking about doing this like this
little friday night or the friday show
we were like three doesn't feel like
enough we need something else right we
got it and we started we started with
this honorable mention that was the
first one right and then because of our
boy ethan schmidt oh you mean carrie
lake's uh campaign messenger exactly
yeah that is where the uh alpha cuck
out of some random
deep
abyss of my brain as we're talking about
him getting owned by a teenager we're
like you know what alf we need a fifth
category here but we need it we need
another category there's just too many
boneheads and we got to stop them and
really we could do like eight nine ten
twelve of these people we just don't
have enough time i know there's not
enough time and it just becomes like
it would everyone would get an award and
look we're not part of this whole
participation award group okay you
really got to do some boneheaded [ __ ] to
win bonehead of the weekend you've gotta
really give it your all but but this
person because they weren't on the pole
but they got the dishonorable mention i
really believe that this is like bone
end of the year type stuff oh this is
affidavit this is crazy [ __ ] man
this guy how many how many documents
let's see let me go back to it here 67
87 oh no no 100 and a hundred and
184 here's the 184. here's the uh the
documents
individual documents this is just in the
first 15 boxes yeah so you got to
remember
nara went down and took these boxes
in may yeah right and this is this is
after this is after
they said hey we're missing this stuff
and they said we don't have this stuff
and they're like we're no we there you
have the super like we thank you yeah
we'll look around maybe
we have it no we don't have it they're
like no you have it and they're like oh
yeah we have some we have some of it
some of it
and then they went down and got 15 boxes
they bring it back to dc
apparently which is also which is also
after the fact of donald trump
going through the [ __ ] files himself
picking out what he wanted he's touching
him yeah he's like yeah this is a good
top secret yeah this might make me some
money boy this is worth a couple million
bucks kim jong-un might like this yeah
whoa i will definitely like this one put
that one in melania's underwear drawer
hey this one needs to go in the safe we
really need to make sure no one sees yes
no one can crack this safe right okay
so from may 16 to may 18th
of this year the fbi agents went through
these first 15 boxes here's what they
found gabe they found in these first 15
boxes 14 of them
had classified documents with classified
uh markings on them and that is
important when you're talking about this
they were marked
classified to some extent which is
important when you when kash patel is
saying he waved his hands over these
documents and he declassified them he
did not declassify them he may have said
it out loud but they're not declassified
if they're not marked properly
he didn't do that
declassification doesn't live only in
donald trump's brain that is not how
this works that's not how our government
works that's not how our system works
that's not how we protect our national
security which he is putting in danger
here but in the in out of 15 14 boxes
contained these documents and there was
184
unique documents not pages
documents right bearing classification
markings so in these 14 boxes there was
184 files in other words of documents
i mean if you want to think of it that
way right because yeah yeah because 184
that sounds like pages but it's not
pages no no no that's actually a packet
or it could be more than one page if
that makes sense
now in that 184 game 67 of them were
marked confidential which is one level
of classification
92 were marked
secret which seems to me i mean if i
were even if i was a layman
and i didn't know anything about
classified documents or how they were
declassified or classified i would
imagine
that secret would probably be something
that i don't know you don't want anyone
to know
yeah you would think that you know if it
contains certain secrets or information
about the country that might put our
security at risk or those who might be
outside of this country like like our
people working for us yeah government to
make sure you wouldn't want to disclose
those things right
seems kind of significant well the other
significant thing here is 25 of them 25
of these 184 documents were marked top
secret now again i'm no classified
document expert here but i am a layman
and i understand that there's
confidentials one thing secret oh that
sounds even more like you don't want
anyone to know but top secret it seems
like that's a classification yeah
they're like only a few handful of
people are supposed to see if they're
like feels like that it just feels like
that maybe we just keep this between us
like a little hush-hush secret like
don't tell don't tell anyone i took a
cookie out of the cookie jar kind of
[ __ ] and you're like top secret like
what
you know like i mean you know i'm not
trying to downplay just the aspect of a
secret but this is one of those things
where like confidential classified top
secret you've got skiff documents like
there is no way that you can rationalize
outside like especially any republicans
that say oh this was an unjust attack of
donald trump he should have had those
documents they agree you know now
they're beginning to say
well he shouldn't have had them
but they're still going with the
argument like uh dan crenshaw saying
this is an unjust attack on the
president totally political attack i
wonder if they're going to start
deleting those tweets i i mean you can't
delete those interviews they did last
sunday
this much this is one of those things
where it's like
you guys double down and then triple
down on an argument that was pretty dumb
to begin with from like from the start
right
you decided to say oh this was either
planted this was either uh fabricated
this was political move by biden uh this
were not actually as bad as the
documents as you might you know uh
describe no it is all of those things
and worse in the fact that this was
illegally taken by a former president
that put our country at risk it wasn't
planted it wasn't fake it wasn't in a
secure location despite the fact that he
said they were in a
two locks and behind a door we're
finding out that it's in multiple
locations scattered across the [ __ ]
compound
that is not
good that is not safe the area is is not
secure and again this this affidavit is
only based on the first 15 boxes right
because in this in this uh 47 this item
47 here in the affidavit it goes on to
say the fbi agent says down at the
bottom based on my training and
experience which you would think that an
fbi agent would have some experience
with classified or confidential
documents i know that documents
classified at these levels typically
contain ndi which is national defense
information which is very important when
you're talking about skiffs because it
doesn't matter what the classification
is a lot of times because they're ndi
they can only be viewed in a certain
area because they have to be remain
secure in a certain way now
it goes on to say and i think this is
very important too i don't want anyone
to um
skate over this fact because i actually
think this has to do with the january 6
part of this
at the very bottom it says several of
the documents also contain what appears
to be
um
the former guy
former potus former president united
states donald trump's handwritten notes
which means that it is
the reason why the fbi brings up these
handwritten notes in this happening is
because they think him having these
handwritten notes is criminal which
means it's either crime to have him or
he's hiding a crime that he did with the
handwritten notes right there's a reason
why they they point out that it's
handwritten notes i mean it's not like
hey get me another diet coke that's not
what this is
this handwritten note is either a
direction of crime or him possessing
these handwritten notes is directly a
crime because maybe he's writing down
with a sharpie notes about classified
information and briefings who knows what
these handwritten notes are but they are
handwritten notes these are the ones he
didn't eat or flush gabe that's the one
yeah what do you what do you put what do
you put on on handwritten notes do you
put ketchup on handwritten notes i think
it's all ketchup is it all ketchup yeah
well i mean what else what else will
help
yeah
i'm wondering just wondering when when
the average american goes to the white
house and grabs the top secret document
or goes to the mar-a-lago you know
stephen dockerman to eat what do they
put on it it's mustard ketchup lettuce
it's it's a it's ketchup it's a sesame
seed bun i don't know no no no no the
paper the paper can be molded into a bun
and i see and the actual contents of
what's inside you know so like you fold
it a long way then fold it again you've
got a double fold in the middle you
throw some ketchup on and you chase it
with a diet coke
what a [ __ ] box dishonorable mention
donald j trump the cheeto dust mobster
the former guy grandpa poopy pants
himself he should have been the bonehead
but we had another winter game we had
another winner yeah yeah the female
version of the former guy
marjorie
uh water green as i mentioned swattery
green that's watery green swaddled with
water taylor green that's what i meant
to say but i used to call her marjorie
hookfoot green but now she's been
changed to swattery taylor green um what
is it ted
marjorie taylor green stepped in that
made her because she was out front i
mean like oh we post this thing she was
the winner yeah
within a matter of seconds i mean at the
end of the she i mean once people see
the video of the poll of the actual like
them going against each other it is
no not even close
even devin nunes and ben shapiro
couldn't compete with swaddling and
taylor green they were like posted on
twitter at tony michael's pod when we
posted it on there boom it was done oh
when i first got on youtube boom ran out
of the gate she was the winner no
question and that's where you go vote
you can vote on youtube on our youtube
channel yeah the tony michaels podcast
you can find it on youtube or you can
you can vote on twitter at tony
michael's pod every single week and
again we we like to put it out early but
sometimes we hold on to that twitter
bowl and that that that bone in a weak
bowl for as long as we can because the
bone heads emerge the boneheads emerge
you can also download the bod the the
bone in the weak every single week
but this bone head this bone head
there's some video of her and the white
house did such a great job that's the
where i want to go with this is because
the white house destroyed uh marjorie
taylor green she was actually i think
she was in the first
part of that um she was the first one
red she was the first one because here's
the thing she and i wouldn't be
surprised if this was a reason uh she
was the most outspoken person
that that decided to in their own
hypocrisy say that these people who had
you know worked to go to school either
uh weren't able to finish or had
mounting loans
that they don't deserve
government aid and and for giving these
loans
and how quickly
the internet was like um let's pull out
the receipts here shall we marge because
what we see here is that you took out up
to 300 or so thousand dollars and 183
thousand dollars was forgiven
so why are wait wait wait wait you mean
you mean she took out a loan that she
knew she was gonna have to pay back
right
she knew she was gonna have to pay her
income dependent on this loan of her
getting is what your assumption was and
you're saying when she had to go pay
back this loan she got a hundred and
eighty three thousand dollars of
forgiveness
it seems like that person would think
when someone goes and gets a loan for
their education i don't know for their
livelihood to think that they would get
a good job or a good paying job she
would she would actually say you know
what you should probably get some relief
if you need it but let's see what she
actually said
let's see what she actually said yeah
but for for our government just to say
you know okay well your debt is
completely forgiven obviously they have
an agenda for that they need votes in
november so the timing is a pure
coincidence there as well but it's
completely unfair and taxpayers all over
the country taxpayers that never took
out a student loan taxpayers that pay
their bills and and and you know maybe
even never went to college or just
hard-working people they shouldn't have
to pay off the great big student loan
debt for for some college student that
piled up massive debt going to some ivy
league school that's not fair
this is really dumb in so many levels
this video is so stupid number one she's
she's assuming that every single person
that's getting their loan
relief for ten thousand dollars went to
an ivy league school nor does she know
that most people go to ivy league
schools are from very wealthy families
like ben shapiro for instance uh they go
to ucla and then they go to like an ivy
league like um harvard law like ben
shapiro went to and they actually their
parents pay for it out of their pocket
now there are several people that do
that work their asses off to get above
the people who can just afford to write
the check for these ivy league schools
and get in these iv schools but a lot of
times they're getting grants and they're
getting scholarships as well because
they're so goddamn smart to get into
these and also like you know i applying
for scholarships and grants are not easy
like i mean there are a ton you mean
it's work you mean it yeah you mean
lazy people these lazy people who just
want to live off the government are
doing work to get into college come on i
mean
i can tell you well let me tell you tony
from my own experience like you know
recipient of the pell grant as well and
like taking out private loans on my
parents you know the parent plus loan
all those things like also
it's
at the time when i was going to school
like there wasn't an easy way to really
i mean they were beginning to be some
ways that you could find these kind of
scholarships or grants or whatever but
you're kind of throwing yourself out
there into the ether and being like i'm
going to apply to this and i'm also
going to be applying with thousands of
other people
for a very narrow amount of money
and i don't know if i'm going to get it
so you're out there applying applying
applying no idea if you're gonna get it
if you'll even hear back it's one of
those things where it's like
it takes a lot of [ __ ] work and the
people who are willing to do the work
right she she in her statement right now
on that show when she gave it she was
putting down she was punching down
everyone
who went to and went to college right or
or started to go to college and had to
drop out for whatever reason or their
their situation changed or whatever it
might be whether they finished or didn't
finish right but she is she is pushing
down
this idea that anyone who took any sort
of assistance any sort of aid
is not
uh
not not someone who should be deserving
of forgiveness from a woman who took
money
and why not like the white house so so
eloquently pointed out here and put her
on blast and the white house tweeted the
dark house i guess we should say is it
the dark white house the dark what is
this because this is the dark the dark
house
the dark house rises type thing yeah we
should like the dark white house the
grey house
but anyways congresswoman uh swattery
excuse me marjorie taylor green had 183
504 dollars in ppp loans forgiven the
reason why we know that is because it's
a government loan and it's government
information yeah when someone gets
forgiven anyone can look these things up
uh oh
um here here's the here's the greatest
part ah 708
a hundred thousand likes holy [ __ ] sixty
two sixty three thousand quote tweets
yeah now a hundred and ninety two
thousand returns they didn't
they did not stop with our bone end of
the week they kept going so we have we
have another congress person vern
buchanan who had over 2.3 million holy
[ __ ] forgiven on the ppp loans the money
we the people loaned him
and we forgave that loan
2.3 million dollars [ __ ] this guy this
piece of [ __ ] because he was on um fake
news here talking about how people are
lazy let's listen here's that was sorry
this is this amount too this amount
wasn't even revealed in that uh
there was that graphic that was going
around with a bunch of people was like
matt gates march hillary green some
other people i don't think i don't think
he was actually in our region talking
about forgiveness alone for the last
four or five months are very very upset
many of them work two jobs to be able to
put their kids through college and then
to think that a lot of these loans are
going to be forgive is wrong and they're
very outraged about it and they've no
they're not no they're not no one's
outraged no one's outraged you dumb son
of a [ __ ] that that people who went to
school who worked hard to go through
school who either finished school or
like gabe said didn't finish school and
they participated in their economy we're
we're at record low unemployment to to
think that all the people that are going
to receive this relief are only people
who are lazy you are a dumb [ __ ]
and they are they are over calculating
here gabe they are over calculating they
are overreaching here and this is gonna
backfire on him big time big time just
gonna backfire him just like vern here
vern that's his [ __ ] name burn um he
got he has 2.3 million it doesn't stop
there now mark wayne
um
millen mullen
of course uh mullen here was talking
about how people are lazy again but he
got 1.4 million million with an m
in ppp loans were given uh congressman
kevin hearn uh over one million he
absolutely says
that uh these people should not have uh
their debt relief for their hard work uh
congressman mike kelly uh pennsylvania
almost a million 987 thousands just shy
of a million ooh and then um a bonad uh
uh normal
he's normally on our bone end of the
week he's i don't know how many times we
need to do that list of how many times
he's yeah we'll give an updated account
to show how many times matt gates marcus
haley green lauren bober and the rest of
the [ __ ] fascist seditionist group
have come onto the show well here is
matt gantz saying he tweeted everyone
knows
that in a 60 billion plus european land
war it's always
the last three billion that kicks in the
door and i don't know what he's tweeting
here the truth
it was oh oh here the three billion
dollars in foreign aid to ukraine he's
talking about ukraine he's a putin's i
gotta say i'm surprised that all of
these tweets have not been deleted by
these people well you know it they
probably they got so many vile tweets it
would be difficult to start deleting
them
482 thousand dollars matt gatz got
forgiven by the federal government by us
but the main person here um
swattery taylor green
this week now revealed which again it's
public information she's punching down
on the american working class receiving
just a slight benefit to help them
relieve their debt which probably in
most cases and even the amount of
interest that people have paid on these
loans throughout the years she received
183 000
in ppp forgiveness that's why she is the
bone end of the week gabe let's give
this bonehead her due
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
swattery taylor green hookfoot green is
bone into the week
you voted you decided we broke it down
just as we do every single friday in the
second hour of the tony michaels podcast
don't forget to subscribe on youtube at
the tony michaels podcast we air live
every single weekday monday through
friday noon eastern 11 central nine
pacific on youtube twitter and twitch
and we simulcast from the midas touch
facebook page and every friday we bring
you bonehead of the week
right here on the tony michaels podcast
and re-airing on midas touch network
don't forget to subscribe to the minus
touch network as well keep up with all
your breaking news why it's important
and how to spread that message and you
can vote on the youtube channel or
follow us on twitter at tonymichaelspod
where you can vote for bonehead of the
week you can also download bonehead of
the week every single week on sunday
apple spotify google your favorite
directory while you're there please
leave us a review and please subscribe
to the audio podcast
this has been this edition of bone hand
of the week
ahead of the week we'll see you next
week stick around we have some great
announcements on the tony michaels
podcast right after the music
[Music]
[Applause]